Okay, welcome back. I hope you enjoyed the animation and learned something from that,
or at least it triggered some different ways to consider the things we experience in terms
of challenges, setbacks, failures and so on. Now let's unpack this. Let's go a bit deeper
on this. This, as I mentioned in the opening intro video, this is so fundamental, this
is so key. Why? Because our life is filled with constant challenges constantly, and of
course you know this. But have we ever stopped to look at what is our relationship to those
setbacks, those failures, those challenges? I know for me a long time ago, when I used
to be experiencing failure like all of us in different areas of life, or challenges, setbacks,
I used to tell myself a negative story about those failures. I would say things like, what's
wrong with me? Why can't I do this? What's wrong with me? And I would be asking the wrong
question in relationship to my setback or my failure, however you want to think of it.
And by constantly asking that question, what's wrong with me because of my failure or my setback,
I was looking in the wrong direction. My power, my internal life force, power, spirit, again,
however you want to think of it, was looking in the wrong way and I was shutting down. I
was shutting down. I was making a story about my failure that was creating more pain for
myself. So I wasn't using the challenges and setbacks as effectively as I could. Now it's
important to consider in some areas of life, we might be stronger at this. We may experience a
challenge or a setback, let's say in a particular thing you're doing at work or in your personal
life. And in that area, you might be able to see it in a more positive way, see it like Thomas
Edison that you learned something, you learned how not to do something, and then you're able to
move forward with more confidence. In another area of life, we might be seeing it in the opposite
way. We might be going, Hey, in this area, I'm just a failure. What's wrong with me? And we start to
tell ourselves negative self talk. Now self talk is one of the components of the Special Forces
military uses, one of their top three for memory. That's part of what they consider very important
to be mentally strong as an elite soldier, the way you talk to yourself, the relationship you have
to yourself. And that's what we're doing as we're unpacking this, we're going, What is our
relationship to challenges and setback and failure? What do we tell ourselves? When we go
through it? What do we tell ourselves when it's something in a personal area or in a work related
area? Do we lean into it? Do we go above the line? If we go back to module, the first module, do we
look for solutions when we have those setbacks? Or do we drop below the line? Do we tell ourselves
negative stories? Do we blame others? How do we see feedback? Now, when we look at this, we go, Okay,
even beyond the animation, I challenge you to play with this in your own mind, just in a very
light way to go, Okay, well, how can I make challenges and setbacks exciting? In fact, I actually,
when they come, I'm leaning into them. I'm expanding into them. Well, one of the things that I would
tell myself and a lot of the clients I used to work with would be a challenge or setback is
a precursor or it's the preview before I'm about to grow. Why? Well, it's no different to going to
the physical gym. When you go to the gym, you know that you have to have resistance for your
muscles to grow. It's a healthy type of stress. And when we go through life, we're taking on
challenges, new, new tasks, new things that are outside our comfort zone. Naturally, we're going
to get setbacks, we're going to get resistance just like we wouldn't at gym. So when these
challenges come, the tension comes, I prefer to get a little bit excited when I can remember to do
this. I don't wait a second, this is how I actually grow. This is the setback right now,
the failure right now, I'm learning something. I'm growing. I'm going to find a solution. So I'm
now having healthier self talk in the face of that adversity and that setback and that challenge. So
now I am consciously cultivating a healthy relationship to failure and setbacks. As Michael
Jordan said, I didn't fail all those times. I just, these are all the shots that I missed. That's
why I am who I am. It's part of the journey. And when you see that, you can integrate, utilize the
information in those challenges, as opposed to what used to happen to myself and so many other
people. And perhaps you can relate to this. When you go through the challenge of the setback, you
actually shut down because you're telling yourself a negative story about the failure of the setback.
So you're not able to absorb the information, to extract knowledge from that particular challenge.
So you don't get to grow in that moment. That's the contrast. So the opportunity or the invitation
now is to choose your relationship to failure and setbacks, to see them as Thomas Edison,
Michael Jordan, to see them as the very pathway to your next leap forward, your next growth,
your next expansion and an opportunity to learn and grow. As opposed to if you just stay comfortable
and safe to try and avoid that, you ain't going anywhere. You're not growing. So the very fact
that you're getting setbacks and challenges is a positive thing. And you can wrestle with them,
you can grow, you can get asked for help, feedback. In fact, this relationship to setbacks and failure,
being feedback connects to something super important, which we're going to explore in a
future module called coachability. How coachable are you? So just to plant a little bit of a seed
of what's coming up is all the top athletes in the world. Pretty much all, there are exceptions,
of course, have coaches, they have mentors, top business leaders. If you go and talk to people
who have been successful in their particular field, they have mentors, people who advise them,
that tell them, hey, you're not doing so well here, you can improve this, you can develop this.
And your attitude to coachability makes a huge difference on how you grow. Now, we're going
to get to that, we'll explore that coming up, but that's definitely connected to your relationship,
to setbacks and failure. Because if you have a negative relationship to it, you're going to shut
down, you're going to get defensive, your ego is going to get triggered. Is this making sense? Is
this resonating? Now I'll give you another piece here. There's three universal fears that we all
share, all of us. And they may all play out in different forms, but each of us share these
three universal fears. And if these three fears or any one of these fears connects with failure or
setbacks or challenges, if it gets triggered, then you're more likely to shut down. So I'm going to
tell you what these three are. The first one is that we all share is I don't belong. The second one
is I'm not loved. And the third one is I'm not enough. So imagine now I'm doing a task of some
kind, whatever it may be. And all of a sudden I failed, I've messed up. I did something wrong. I
had a setback and I run the story. I'm not enough. People are going to see me is not good now.
My universal fear that has got triggered. And if I'm afraid that I'm not going to be enough, maybe
I'm not going to be loved. Maybe I'm not going to belong here in this group of people. I'm going to
be rejected. Now these fears are very strong. And they're now starting to shut me down. My nervous
system is activating. It's getting out of balance. I'm releasing cortisol and I'm shutting down. So
this is why it's absolutely key. And you see this with people like Michael Jordan, Thomas, and so
many people, so many people, they separate those fears. They have nothing to do with failure. In fact,
failure and feedback is the way setbacks is the way that's how I grow. Even in the in the US,
there's a culture of entrepreneurship, where people who do new startups and businesses,
if you haven't found at least once, they don't really trust you. Completely different to other
cultures. Why? Because they know that you've had a go. You leaned in, you've failed, you've been hurt,
you've got back up again, and you're moving forward again. That's character, that's resilience,
that's a good mindset. That's the relationship to failure that we're looking at here is seeing it
as growth, seeing it as the way forward, seeing it as opportunity, seeing it as right there,
say is love. Why love? Because without those challenges, you ain't growing. And growth is a
fantastic thing. It's a wonderful thing to grow and expand as a human being. And so there we have
that's no failure, only feedback. And feedback is love. It helps us grow. It's what we need.
It's what nourishes us. So I hope you've enjoyed this module and I'll see you in the next one.